[موسيقى]
ما يجعل هذا فريدًا جدًا والذي يعد
أيضًا جزءًا مهمًا من الإرث
هو موقعه في قلب
المدينة التعليمية المدينة التعليمية بها الكثير
من المؤسسات الرائدة التي تقود
مدارس الجامعات وسيكون هذا ملعبًا
يمكنهم استخدامه للترفيه
والرياضة  المرافق
بعد كأس العالم ، تحتوي
جميع الملاعب الأخرى لدينا على أربع نجوم ،
مما يجعلها فريدة من نوعها أيضًا مع التأكد من
أن
كل شيء بدءًا من 85 بالمائة من
المواد قد تم
استيراده إقليمياً ، 25 من المواد
المعاد تدويرها ،
الإضاءة في جميع أنحاء الاستاد
، أنظمة المياه والري المستدامة
و  بالطبع أيضًا
تقنية التبريد التي تجعل جميع ملاعبنا
[موسيقى]
فريدة من نوعها
[موسيقى
] عوملت بشكل غير عادل ، نعم في رأيي
كثيرًا ، لذلك أعتقد أن قطر
قد حكم عليها من قبل محكمة
الإدراك في
وقت مبكر جدًا